أجنبي
[موسيقى]
وأنا أحب أه أيضًا أهل حلب الآخرين
ولكن الشيء هو أن الله له
أهمية بيئية ومعمارية أكثر أهمية بكثير من
العديد من المدن في المنطقة ربما كما
يمكنك أن تقول اسطنبول
القاهرة هي تلك الأهمية في المنطقة
دمشق أيضًا مهمة بالطبع،
أرى أنها واحدة من
الهيكل التجاري وهي واحدة من
أهم المدن في جميع أنحاء العالم، ومن
المحزن جدًا بالطبع أن أرى هذا القدر الكبير
منها مدمرًا كما لو أن شخصًا ما ينظر من الخارج، فأنا
لست كذلك.  العيش في مختبرنا، لذا فإن هذا ليس
ألمي، بل يجب أن يكون ألم الأشخاص الذين
يعيشون هناك، وأنا
قلق جدًا بشأن الأشخاص من هانا ولكن
كان من الجيد أن يكون لدينا الكثير من الأشخاص
من الآخرين يأتون ويعملون
معنا.  نقوم الآن بتوثيق كبير حول
مدينة حلب للسماح
بمستقبل إعادة الإعمار، حيث تم تدمير هذه المدينة وليس
لديك أي صورة
عنها ولا خطة لا يمكنك إعادة
بنائها، لذا واجبنا الآن أن نقول نحن
كمؤرخين أننا نحضر كل ما  المواد
معًا يمكن للآخرين البدء في
إعادة الإعمار وقد تم تدمير هذا، كما ترى
لا تزال ثقوب الرصاص من
الحرب العالمية الثانية، لقد ولدت
بعد 20 عامًا من الحرب العالمية الثانية،
لم أر
أطلالًا بدأ الناس في إعادة البناء
بالطبع من أجل  سوريا أكثر صعوبة وبالنسبة
لألمانيا ولكن يمكن
إعادة بناء كل شيء، لذا فهي ليست نهاية التاريخ،
هذا مهم جدًا وهذا أيضًا هو
الشيء الذي نريد أن نقوله من خلال
برنامجنا نعم إنه مؤلم، إنه يؤلم كثيرًا
ما ضاع ولكنه مستمر، نحن
نواصل  سنعيش وسنعيد
البناء وسنعيد البناء ونفعل
شيئًا جديدًا من القديم وربما يكون هذا
درسًا يمكنك تعلمه من
ألمانيا لأن هذه المدينة دمرت ولم تكن
قادرة على الصمود، فقد دمرت بعض المدن
مرتين مرة بسبب الحرب
والأخرى بسببها  الآخرون من خلال إعادة الإعمار
ولكن إذا قمت بذلك بعناية وحسن، فلن نتمكن من
نفس المدينة بعد الآن، إنها
مدينة جديدة ولكننا جميعًا نعلم أننا نستطيع كل ما يمكننا
الاستمرار فيه في التاريخ وهذا
شيء جميل مع قدوم السوريين إلى هنا
إذا كانوا كذلك  يأتون إلى هنا ويرون أن
برلين كانت
على أرض الواقع لم يعرفوا أه
سأرى أنها برلين اليوم
أم نعم 70 بعد 80 عامًا مدينة حية
ثم إنهم مليئون بالأمل يقولون حسنًا،
التاريخ مستمر وهذا مهم جدًا